>> Todd: IT'S OFFICIAL, HOUSE
REPUBLICANS HAVE GAINED MAJORITY
IN THE HOUSE BY CLINCHING 218
SEATS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN CONGRATULATING
KEVIN McCARTHY SAYING HE'S READY
TO WORK WITH HOUSE REPUBLICANS
TO DELIVER RESULTS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES.
>> Carley: DAVID WEBB JOINS US
NOW.
IT IS OFFICIAL, WASHINGTON NO
LONGER UNDER ONE PARTY RULE,
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> IT MEANS THERE IS A LITTLE
HOPE, YOU CAN BLOCK, CHALLENGE,
SUBPOENA THIS LEFTIST AGENDA
GOING ON UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
BIDEN CONGRATULATING
REPUBLICANS?
SKILLED POLITICAL LIAR FOR
DECADES AND YOU SUDDENLY BELIEVE
HE'S TELLING YOU THE TRUTH, HE'S
HAPPY?
BIDEN IS HAPPY REPUBLICANS WON?
LET THAT SINK IN FOR A MOMENT.
>> Todd: YOU ARE NOT BUYING THAT
AM PROIS?
HERE IS KEVIN McCARTHY ON THE
FUTURE OF THE GOP COMING
TOGETHER.
LISTEN.
>> WE ARE THE LAST LINE OF
DEFENSE SO WE CAN'T TAKE THIS
PERSONAL, WE CAN'T GO OUT AND
MAKE OUR OWN INDIVIDUAL IDEAS,
WE NEED TO WORK AS A TEAM FOR
THE SAKE OF THIS NATION.
>> Todd: THAT'S THE QUESTION,
DAVID, WITH SUCH A SLIM
MAJORITY, WILL REPUBLICANS BE
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER TO PUT THE
BRAKES ON WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO
OUR GRADUATE COUNTRY OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS?
>> WHETHER BY ONE OR 10, THEY
HAVE THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMANSHIP
AND THAT MATTERS HERE.
FOR KEVIN  McCARTHY FOR ALL THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP, CAN THEY
REEL THE POWER OF THE PURSE?
CAN THEY WIELD THE HOUSE RULES?
CAN THEY SHUT DOWN SOME AGENDA
TAKING MONEY OUT OF OUR POCKETS?
NOT JUST AMERICANS, YOU AND ME,
WE'RE AMERICANS, OUR MONEY IS
BEING TAKEN AWAY, GIVEN AWAY,
UNRESTRICTED SPENDING BY THE
LEFTIST PARTY THAT IS DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
>> Carley: WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING, WHEN YOU LISTEN TO
INTERVIEWS OF NEWLY ELECTED
REPUBLICANS WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATIONS, THEY SAY NO,
THAT IS SOMETHING THEY ARE OKAY
WITH HAPPENING, BUT NOT THEIR
FOCUS.
THEY SAY THEY CAMPAIGNED ON
KITCHEN TABLE ISSUES AND THAT IS
WHAT THEY WANT TO DELIVER.
>> ITS HAD TO BE BOTH.
YOU CAN CAMPAIGN, YOU CANNOT
FORGET THERE NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNT
ABLTS AND THEY CAN MULTI TASK.
WHAT I DON'T LIKE IN WASHINGTON,
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE NOW, THAT IS
MY LEGISLATIVE VOICE.
>> Carley: I LIKE IT.
>> THIS ISSUE RIGHT NOW, MULTI
TASK, 435, YOU HAVE MAJORITY 218
AND WILL LIKELY GAIN MORE SEATS.
IF YOU DO IT RIGHT AND WORK WITH
THE STAFF AND PROFESSIONAL
STAFFERS, YOU CAN CONDUCT BOTH,
BE A LEGISLATIVE BODY, BE AN
INVESTIGATIVE BODY AND LET'S
FACE IT, THERE HAS NOT BEEN
ACCOUNTABILITY IN WASHINGTON ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE AND
THERE NEEDS TO BE THAT AND KEVIN
McCARTHY NEEDS TO CHANGE THE
RULES IN THE HOUSE.
IN '75, THEY GAVE THE SPEAKER
TOO MUCH POWER, CHANGE THAT AND
GET BACK TO REGULAR ORDER,
THATTEN MOOS KEVIN McCARTHY
SHOULD BE ASKED ARE YOU GOING
BACK TO REGULAR IN THE HOUSE
MAJORITY?
>> Todd: FRESH PITCH TO WELCOME
MORE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO
THIS COUNTRY.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WE HAVE A POPULATION THAT IS
NOT REPRODUCING ON ITS OWN WITH
THE SAME LEVEL THAT IS USED TO,
THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A GREAT FUTURE IN ESHG M, IS IF
WE WELCOME AND EMBRACE
IMMIGRANTSES, GOAL IS TO HELP
DREAMERS AND GET A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR ALL 11 MILLION.
>> Todd: DAVID, THEY ARE NOT
HIDING IT, THEY WANT DEMOCRAT
VOTERS, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
STATEMENT?
>> ANYBODY BEEN LIED TO LATELY?
HOW MANY DECADES, NOT YEARS,
DECADES AND ESPECIALLY SINCE
REAGAN AMNESTY, HAVE YOU HEARD
DEMOCRATS LIE TO ILLEGAL ALIENS,
BLENDED FAMILIES, WE WILL GIVE
YOU A PATH TO CITIZENSHIP.
IT IS ANOTHER LIE.
HISPANICS HAVE YOU HAVE MOOED IN
EXIT POLLING AND SURVEY OF
115,000 VOTERS AND RESPONDENTS
IN THE 94,000 RANGE, AP FOUND
PEOPLE MOVE ON ISSUE AND
HISPANICS MOVED ON DEMOCRATS,
JUST LIKE BLACKS AND JUST
LIKE -- HE IS PANNEDORING, DON'T
BUY THE LIE.
THEY LIE TO PEOPLE WHO COME HERE
SEEKING SOMETHING BETTER ACROSS
THE BORDER AND -- HOLD IT, I'M
SORRY, THIS TIME YOU ARE GOING
TO GET SOME.
>> Carley: WHAT A DIFFERENCE A
LITTLE OVER A DECADE MAKES, IN
2009, CHUCK SCHUMER SAID ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IS WRONG.
HE SAID, ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
WRONG, PEOPLE WHO ENTER WITHOUT
OUR PERMISSION ARE ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND SHOULD NOT BE TREATED
THE SAME AS PEOPLE WHO ENTER
LEGALLY.
THAT IS 2009.
LISTEN TO 2022, AMNESTY FOR 11
MILLION MIGRANTS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> LOOKING FORWARD TO TONIGHT.
>> Carley: GOING TO BE FUN.
>> I'M WEARING THE ORIGINAL ONE
AND ONLY FIRST OF ITS KIND FOX
NATION WATCH.
>> Carley: LOOK AT THAT.
>> FIRST DAY, FIRST SET, FIRST
VIDEO, I WAS WEARING THIS WATCH
ON FOX NATION, H